the first couple of thor movies lacked a
little something at least when compared
to the likes of iron man and captain
america the winter soldier
that all changed when director taika
waititi came on board to help thor
ragnarok the third installment to the
series and a film that completely
changed what was possible within the
marvel cinematic universe
platitude will be coming back for the
sequel thor love and thunder and based
on everything we know about the film so
far
he's going to take these heroes in even
wilder directions than before
in addition to having the guardians of
the galaxy player role jane foster
played by natalie portman is returning
to the superhero franchise after being
absent from ragnarok
this time around though she's not just
playing a love interest she's donning
the title of mighty thor herself
and by the looks of an exclusive behind
the scenes photo that looper obtained
from backgrid she's taking the part very
seriously
but preparing for her big superhero role
by never skipping arm day shouldn't come
as a surprise to anyone familiar with
portman's career
the academy award winner has always gone
above and beyond to reflect the
characters she plays
most famously she actually shaved her
head when her character had to do the
same in v for vendetta but even that
pales in comparison to what she had to
do for black swan
ballerinas naturally have to be in
exceptional physical condition to dance
the way they do
and to properly showcase the art form
portman reportedly trained six days a
week
for up to eight hours a day so that she
could really dance like a ballerina
her training regimen there was obviously
different from what she's doing to
become thor
but it's clear she has the perseverance
to adhere to any workout schedule
even when natalie portman isn't
necessarily training for a role she
knows how to stay in shape
in a 2019 interview with women's health
the mega star discussed how she keeps up
her strength even when her schedule gets
hectic
as she described it i run maybe three
times a week when i'm running for a full
hour it feels a little like meditation
to me
later she discusses how she's a fan of a
style of exercise known as gyrotonics
which essentially consists of movements
you'll find with tai chi yoga gymnastics
and other disciplines all wrapped into
one convenient package
ultimately it sounds like she keeps an
open mind and exercises in whatever
manner is most convenient in the moment
stating i used to do ashtonga but now
i'll just get there and i'll try
anything
considering the results we'd say this
routine has definitely worked well for
her
and what portman has shared in public
about her training so far sounds brutal
she went on the tonight show starring
jimmy fallon to offer an update on thor
love and thunder and while shooting
hadn't started at the time portman was
already being put through the ringer
and from the sound of things she wasn't
exactly in the best place mentally to
start an intense regimen
she told fallon i'm trying i've had like
months of like pandemic you know eating
baked goods and like lying in bed and
feeling sorry for myself
i'm like super tired after working out
yeah and during
yeah and dreading before around that
same time she also stopped by watch what
happens live with andy cohen where she
was asked if she had to be on a workout
plan similar to her co-star chris
hemsworth
she said that she was and she wasn't
taking to it very easily
yes i am training and i'm in so much
pain like i'm not good at this
maddie black formerly a crossfit coach
with vogue fitness offered some of her
insight into how portman could
accomplish such gains in an interview
with allen live
she said natalie will be carrying out
lots of compound weightlifting
movements such as squatting pressing and
pulling in order to remain lean for the
role she'll be implementing some
high-intensity interval training into
her weekly routine
she goes on to explain how she would go
about designing an exercise regimen for
someone wanting the kind of arms jane
foster's thor
has in the comics declaring
weightlifting would form the foundation
base whilst functional training would
develop skills
improve flexibility and enhance
endurance we may not know exactly how
heavy her weights are but it's
definitely clear she's been pumping iron
in one way or another
we didn't think there was any way
portman could look more intimidating
than in her natalie raps video
but judging from those guns she just
proved this wrong
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one